the supreme court's decision striking
down roe v wade could create a new wave
of pregnant people traveling to states
where abortion is more widely available
take a look at this map for instance
illinois which has strong abortion
protections in place is surrounded by
states that have or could have
restrictions on the procedure so here's
a question will illinois be ready to
handle thousands of new abortion
patients adriana diaz is at a planned
parenthood clinic in waukegan illinois
just eight miles from the wisconsin
border she's looking at grass hoops
efforts to help women travel to get
abortions adriana good morning to you
good morning gil opponents to abortion
tell us they are very concerned that
tens of thousands of women will be
traveling here to illinois to get the
procedure but planned parenthood
actually opened this facility so close
to the wisconsin border to provide that
access and other groups have volunteers
transporting women both within illinois
and from out of state and they're about
to get busier
lori who lives north of chicago
says getting behind the wheel is an act
of activism i've had people sleep the
entire way home so people falling asleep
in this back seat right here yeah with
this blanket with that very same blanket
she drives women who need a ride to get
an abortion both locally and from out of
state
lori is a volunteer with the midwest
access coalition known as mack the
non-profit helps fund everything from
lodging and transportation to child care
for women who need those resources to
get the procedure
she says she's driven about 20 women in
the last three years what do you
remember about the last woman yeah she
was a single mom she wasn't getting a
lot of support from her former husband
and she said i i just can't manage it
much as i would like to
and it was just it was
it was heartbreaking and it was
encouraging at the same time that she
had
an avenue to
terminate her pregnancy because she
wanted to and felt she needed to
with roe overturned planned parenthood
estimates that up to 30 thousand
additional patients could travel to
illinois for abortions over the next
year
people in illinois are going to be
feeling a ripple effect ahead of the
supreme court's decision we spoke to
diana parker kafka executive director of
mac
she said demand for the organization's
services had already tripled this year
your phones are ringing off the hook
yeah like my phone's vibrating every
five seconds now really yeah
she worries without roe illinois health
care facilities will be stretched to
capacity you expect people will have to
be turned away
oh yeah yeah there will be people that
we won't be able to see through
their abortion care that need it and
we're also thinking about plans and how
to
support those people there are
anti-abortion rights activists who
believe that it's wrong to help women
cross state lines to get an abortion if
she's coming from a state where it's
banned what do you say to them i don't
think
bodily autonomy
should be limited by borders
these are people making a decision that
is really essential for their lives for
their families is your organization
helping people women skirt state laws
i wouldn't say they're skirting state
laws if someone has a an appointment at
a clinic in illinois and that care is
legal then we absolutely will help them
get there and for some volunteers like
lori their passion is personal she had
an abortion in her 30's before she was
ready for a family i knew immediately i
thought there's no way i'm going to have
a child right now
i was lucky it was after row i'm old
enough to
clearly
remember before row was passed and i
know what those experiences were like
she says ensuring access to safe legal
abortions is what drives her is it hard
dropping folks off yes
yes it is
it is i think about them walking through
the doors
they stay with me and it reinforces my
commitment to to keep on doing this
as long as necessary which is looking
like it's going to be a while
[Applause]
it is not a crime for a woman to travel
to another state for an abortion in fact
justice brett kavanaugh noted in his
concurring opinion that interstate
travel is protected under the
constitution also some local prosecutors
in places like st louis missouri and
dallas texas have said they will not
prosecute anyone who helps a woman get
an abortion despite the bans in those
states tony
all right adriana some powerful
information there are 30 000 new
patients potentially thank you very much